and yeah I don't want to welcome for
this video I already have lights on but
it's a little dark him yeah it's a
getting darker late in the day here
let's see what happens
pricks RP doulas is the opponent it's a
long name and we got the have fun h3
I've gotten this only today and so in
the pen tablets
that's a funny move my memory I played
aged five and that's in that game which
feels weird hey if I just go d5 I mean
how bad can there be just grabbing the
center this is a perfectly normal
position with colors reversed and in
this case what is aged shot six to me
it's only it does make some sense
securing the kingside a little bit yeah
with the cursor first I think white
castle's yeah I probably I probably have
to do it here as well Bishop d7 is
extremely lame that's to name
so I have to give it give it give him
that pawn but the question is how do i
do i really have enough compensation I
think with colors reversed and H pawned
on age 7 the IDN lie to g5 is an idea
really the ideas an idea and this idea
is a serious serious option and they
don't have that now still a little bit
surprised that he invests time when he
has to grab on c6 I take you 5 otherwise
so maybe he is considering how to take
but Bishop takes pawn takes Knight takes
makes a really strange impression
I mean Knight 92 6b takes Bishop takes
rook b8 must be the must be right at
least it looks er looks correct
yeah it surprised him because I thought
what he is doing really just Placer
reversed Owens defends with his extra
move and it looked like here has
prepared this idea in a way me not not
particularly for this game but it felt
like something that he was aiming for a
bit surprising that he invests time now
he basically has to do that and here you
can actually make an argument for Bishop
b2 not grabbing okay so Bishop to a6 is
probably too strong a medicine here it's
interesting if he castles in this in
this position without the H pawn I would
be really able to sacrifice on h2 the
classic the classic sacrifice
really
[Music]
so surprising move the table actually
okay it's detecting these five but he is
allowing Bishop to a six
eighty-three a trust to Bob I also seems
that that was an idea of the Georgian
great Baxter sorry
been a long game
yeah bishop basics is so interesting
it should take 90 X 90 X Queen g5 is
just excellent for black from the
winning from like 95 that is something
else
you should base 692 highest Knight takes
bishop takes so it seems like I don't
have anything there we should be 43 and
no good continuation
you
yeah I try to find something a bit more
full thing I actually believe that I
have a very decent compensation almost
no matter what I play but I'm not quite
sure how to do it how to play it the
best possible way
take it into carefully light you for as
an option
look b6 it's really really weird that
1985 should work but it seems to work
Knight takes Bishop takes there's
nothing good there I mean it looks
terrible actually I think for white with
and it's nothing on 25 Bishop takes e4
and somehow white holes okay we create
p8
we have a normally active piece play
it's it's probably not enough yeah I'm
down three pawns three points is really
really a lot
I wonder like Bishop e6 he goes night
beehive is the problem and I definitely
don't want to give you my King's Bishop
that would be I'll be weird but it's an
irritating move anyway okay I'm and
Bishop a six-night takes a knight takes
Bishop takes Queen g5 we should be for
op8 networking
Queen f3 probably and Bishop III check I
put a really active position come on
at the end I cannot resist yeah right
now against to take almost I cannot
believe that is can he can players
player slow moves all 95 95 to 55 25
Bishop f4 rook e8 Queen f3 check on 85
c3 Bishop a 3 this is the line long line
row line but I don't see why it
shouldn't work
yeah does he have any other move
actually they're taking take what the
bishop doesn't really do much
just light takes night eggs and cream g5
so much for he has to grab the porn okay
so he cannot castle and we should be for
Bishop b5 is the idea any other way
to prevent this the special p5 move
you
and yeah probably not probably not
okay after Bishop e5 fine I can we
should be for for example Bishop b5 I
can win the pawn back it is somewhat
uninspiring though and T is able to
cancel it should be a bishop before
Bishop define I can take with the
recruit takes pawn takes Bishop takes
that is keeping him and canceled for
quite a while but it's also a bunch of
bunch of material it's interesting okay
let's start with this move
yeah Bishop desire so I can just regain
the pawn one sec the exchange I just
recognize that he can actually take a
seven at the end which is probably good
probably just good
hmm man it's it's the pain it's not good
I cannot set the exchange unfortunately
that's it's really not good what do I
play can I can drop it back and just
claim I have a coin of compensation
which is not entirely untrue probably
but it's not ideal where do I go c8 only
to c8
you know probably your castle
I can go c6 here and push him back I
don't know if it helps the look on the
six would be cool if I could get that in
but I think I just do this he cannot
take because I capture c3 and play Queen
c7 it it takes both bishops on the C
file so he has to go Bishop b2 and then
I have to drum up an attack somehow
which is possible I mean it's a fairly
active setup for me but how exactly it
should be six for Queen d7 I really
don't understand the time management
here I mean he has to go back to e2
anyway okay so
the question is shall I try to play for
that sacrifice just just develop and I
try that try the developing way I like
the b-pawn but this is currently not a
big thing as White has a little play
against my center there's no c4 and so
on
he can play Knight a2 and then try a sea
forward it's extremely slow and it would
blunder c4 at the moment due to the book
being on the B files all night A to B
should be 64 I can just take so he wants
to play Bishop a3 in this position okay
so I have to move the Queen anyway so
now I'm threatening Bishop f3 that
that's dangerous we should to a3 now I
can take the knight so that doesn't work
and we should take sage 3 how does he
actually prevent that move the rook
still immensely dangerous
yeah with all those pieces be to end the
night it's hard to believe that this
wouldn't work it must be at least enough
for draw which taking into account the
time situation I would probably not hate
to play the draw or maybe he plays f4
F for Bishop takes h3 is probably not
enough we should take context context
you gave to so maybe the F pawn move
make some sense here
yeah so we plays it
yeah ticking ticking again doesn't
doesn't do much on age three I mean
they're taking activate them
not happy
yeah but all of a sudden whites pieces
actually I liked em what kind of
corrupts that he plays all those strange
moves queen c1 and whatever and then
miraculously like f4 works as if three
is covered and so on what a strange game
sometimes ya know white is active
don't even have Bishop f5
put a strange game what a strange
strange game okay so trying Bishop to c7
426
and form and from the action take and
play that close position
I'm not sure that I'm threatening
anything United force probably okay
I should have played Knight to e4 yeah
anyway that is almost certainly my next
move
don't understand that move putting it
into a completely empty diagonal while
I'm attacking surprising okay so taking
on edge three years probably not working
yet and I need I need to rope here hook
on the second on the six round with my
night a force the problem yeah okay
let's gain a bit more space
still not so easy to convert the pawn
I mean there's still lots of things
going on we it's very cool about it
you're playing Bishop III Bishop c5 but
don't quite know how to do this only
have to prevent the knight move and now
look at one and the bishop he is very
strong
covering f8 so I cannot get to look over
and even Luke takes a five comes into
consideration
stepheson to action to do much yet
I was thinking 27 but then he can he can
actually sacrifice on i-5 h4 Wow
you open the H file for me yes or the
city like g3 book h2 we're playing
fantastic stuff the set work down 30
seconds here and I cannot move my pieces
normally can I go Queen to f7 and then
bring it over to the King slide Queen f7
may be continued TG folder should go
ahead sense of it fantastic
the move King g7 let's decide
potentially
maybe just place G for like completely
unfazed by everything
and it continues so lots of easy fun to
play it's got a couple of weaknesses
still and I'm catching up on time a
little bit they looked at him on the
radar is f4 in the right moment but Jung
doesn't work yet doesn't work yet
[Music]
sighs 54 okay I can kick with the Jeep
on I was thinking about that was
terrible now I was just losing my lives
there with no time on the clock
I can just now I cannot just take my h2
is hanging it's still not super easy
even though 16 seconds is really really
tough to handle now damn it
yes of course failing to some stupid
trick with no time damn it now takes
with and right yeah whatever I'm
checkmated what a strange game yeah so
let's have a look there
yeah I mean the main issue was probably
burning so much time in the opening and
the time obviously left at the end yeah
it was really really difficult so in the
opening only yeah
three not much else I mean sacrificing
this is kind of normal maybe it's not
the only thing to do with okay so 93
Oh should be six and then a four yeah I
was it took enough time to this this and
I wanted to play Queen g5 what's my plan
I just want to check what I planned
Queen f3 and then I was thinking check
c3 Bishop e3 and the deadlines actually
correct
but King D 1 success winning by the
engine yeah well I mean I've sacrificed
ton of pawns but ok give it a 4 it
should be hope they should be fired
now I cannot take as heaviness honey so
I cannot just like get it back as a
Semler station that's why I played
Bishop c8 I mean I've selected
compensation we should be true and now I
think it's Queen to see one I detected
this kind of things really upset me that
this kindness movers somehow good to get
move Queen d7 and now everything's
perfect platform remarkable
maybe Bishop f5 now and not disappear we
should be three help them I mean the
position still is reasonably difficult
and I know the diminution has to have no
time here this line I mean not sure
about I mean each voice is Christmas bit
of a shorter and four seems to be good
or at least an option but at the time I
had to play really quickly
so this and what should i yam
threatening this move and now I click on
each phone ok that's interesting I
didn't have time for that so why 24 head
was a really remarkable move talk mean
f76 g3 now my main issue was at 4 I mean
the position was was worse but somehow I
got I lost my nerve
there were therefore I just have to
continue talking now
93m I didn't I'd only looked at night
eggs before not 9 H 5 but it is
objectively lost already and 97 this is
really a weird move who is not taking
with the rook maybe someone who sees
that 97 is made in line and rooks g7s
only made in 14 anyway at the end oh
gosh a community huh tough game this h3
is apparently new idea I mean it can
never be an advantage for white quite
clearly with interesting so here the
ending wants to cancel or take and of
course why can a black black can always
play something conservative but I wanted
to play more actively yeah it was a
tough game thanks for watching